salut aujourd'hui vous allez devoir de
venir de super détecteur de mensonges
voici le concept loïc a fouillé sur
internet plein d'infos qu'on trouve sur
moi il a fait une petite sélection que
je vais vous lire mais certaines sont
fausses sauf que évidemment je vais vous
dire qu'elles sont toutes vraies et
c'est à vous de trouver quand est-ce que
je mens il en a rajouté quelques unes
qui l'a inventée à partir de choses
qu'il a lu pour ça il a écumé les sites
d'info les blogs les articles de presse
les réseaux sociaux il a même été
fouillé dans votre petit coucou
pourquoi ça fait ch look ans dit il à
fouiller mes petits coups qui elle-même
le redire ça me fait encore chelou à la
fin de la vidéo je vous donnerai les
réponses et on verra votre score à
l'information de la plus haute
importance
la vidéo que vous êtes en train de
regarder et sponsorisé par north vpn qui
est un vpn dont vous trouverez 1 lire
dans la description avec une énorme
réduction et un mois gratuit utilise
énervé peine ça permet de sécuriser
votre navigation est aussi d'éviter que
vos infos personnelles traînent un peu
partout comme les miennes par exemple
qu'on va utiliser dans cette vidéo
norvégienne est compatible sur tous les
os sur les smart tv sur tous les mobiles
et même sur votre routeur j'ai testé
depuis novembre et c'est vraiment cool
sponsorisés ou pas c'est vraiment un bon
vpn jeu puis aussi m'en servir quand
j'étais en décembre en thaïlande pour
regarder des replays français qui était
inaccessible depuis là-bas vous avez à
lire dans la description avec une
réduction de 75% sur l'abonnement et en
plus un code cumulables pour avoir un
mois gratuite vous permettra aussi
d'essayer
c'est parti pour le concept de la vidéo
à chaque fois je vais vous dire ce que
loïc à trouver ou a écrit ensuite je
dois vous convaincre que c'est vrai
hypothèse numéro une
selon loïc en 24 heures j'ai fait du
mentalisme en polynésie en turquie donc
c'est vrai tu choisis du mentalisme à
tahiti et après j'ai pris un avion et je
suis allé en turquie et j'ai fait du
mentalisme après mais genre dirais que
j'enchaînais ce à quoi pourquoi pourquoi
de chaud tu choisis pas y avait un
festival du rire à tahiti c'était le
deuxième festival du rire de tahiti
d'ailleurs et qui a été le dernier
d'ailleurs et ensuite je travaillais en
fait pour un bateau de croisière un
croisiériste qui était à istanbul en
turquie et ont remonté après la mer
noire des corps et s'était
je crois en 2013 2012 2013 2014 2013
peut-être on reviendra de toute manière
à la fin sur tout ce qui était vrai tout
ce qui était faux je vous expliquerai un
peu mieux hypothèse numéro 2 j'ai donné
des cours de cartomagie à nicolas
sarkozy fin c'est vrai t'as trouvé ça
c'est vrai ça c'est vrai quoi je vous le
dis tout de suite ça c'est la vérité
tu as des questions posées par rapport à
ça oui ce sera toujours très question
pourquoi dans quel contexte
en fait je n'étais pas encore élu
président mais il était en campagne mais
c'était avant et je travaillais au don
camillo à paris dont 15000 l'eau à paris
c'est un cabaret d'humoristes etc on
peut manger et où que j'allais souvent à
travailler là-bas et il y avait une
soirée privée
ça a été privatisée pour la remise de la
légion d'honneur de rachida dati et il a
adoré les cartes et machins et tout est
donc il m'a demandé si je donnais des
cours pour que lui puisse en faire aux
enfants dans sa famille je sais pas quoi
tu as et jeudi grave que je trouvais ça
ouvre de pouvoir faire ça et j'avais
donné mon numéro à son directeur de
cabinet et en fait quand il a été élu
fin de campagne et où je suis c'est mort
il me rappellera jamais et une fois il
m'a rappelée par il m'a rappelé que le
directeur de cabinet je suis allée à
l'elysée directement et je vais donner
un petit cours fait voir des tours très
simple ce qu'on appelle les tours
automatiques qui a pas de manipulation
ça peut pas rater et je devais revenir
et il m'a jamais rappelé après sa salle
mais une fois dans ma vie j'ai donné des
cours de cartes magic à nicolas next
hypothèse troyes ac hypermnésique ben je
suis hypermnésique c'est vrai ça c'est
ça c'est une vérité mais je pense que
tout le monde le sait et à des questions
c'est une capacité à tout retenir en
fait c'est là le fait de ne pas oublier
exactement comme ça je sais pas si tu te
change des fois nex hypothèse 4 g co
écrit par jeff pana clock
ben ça c'est vrai par exemple tu vois
comme les trois autres c'est ça c'est la
vérité
des questions j'écris énormément de
passage télé pour lui qu écrit un de
passage télé pour lui chez patrick
sébastien un pilote de webséries aussi
qu'on peut trouver sur internet
donc il ya bien mon nom à la fin du
générique donc ça c'est vrai comme le
reste hypothèse 5
j'ai reçu le premier prix aux canes d'or
de la magie à cannes
bah c'est vrai ouais en cartomagie en
fait il ya un prix que romilly sur seine
pour la magie de scène il ya un prix car
hormis pour le close up donc c'est la
magie rapprochée et j'avais lu premier
prix pour le club en 2001 2007 bien sûr
next avec l'hypothèse 6 je parle cinq
langues ardent faut que je compte quand
même
ah oui donc c'est vrai à temps non
attends ah oui si c'est vrai c'est vrai
c'est vrai je parle français anglais par
l'espagnol
je parle polonais je parle thaïlande
sabai images parlent chime al saïdi
mypok une claque
coramh chez bart somers non ça c'est du
polonais tu vois c'est un petit peu
c'est vrai vous fait pas voir c'est vrai
nex il pesait 7
ma soeur est également mentalist alors
ça c'est vrai je pense c'est la première
fois qu'on en parle sur la chaîne à part
ceux qui me suivent sur facebook qu'ils
ont pu le voir alors allant vite pas du
tout allez juste dans les compétences
est dans les intérêts qu'elle ait eu
dans sa vie et dans ce cas là capable de
faire et dans ce cas-là compris à les
mentalistes bien en fait on s'est
vraiment une passion commune
elle était beaucoup plus portée sur les
cô tes influences suggestions hypnose et
moi c'est plus sur le côté lecture non
verbale fonctionnement du cerveau et
tout mais c'est un trip comme un conte a
aussi un petit peu avec ma mère que je
pense que les parents transmettent des
choses en fait quand mon père ne
regardez jamais le sport mais on n'a
jamais été intéressé par le sport je
pense quand il ya quand même des trucs
qui se véhicule next 8e hypothèse je
connais pierre cros max bird
vérino depuis plus de huit ans avant
bien avant qu'ils ne fassent des vidéos
ça c'est vrai complètement eh bien on se
connaît on se connaît de la scène de la
scène humoristique à paris parce qu'en
fait il ya plein de plateau il ya des
espèces de génération d'humour et on se
retrouvait toujours à faire les mêmes
plateaux etc
à l'époque c'était vérino vraiment le
boss de notre de cette team là dans le
sens c'était lui qui était le plus connu
avec on n'demande qu'à en rire et c'est
un machin
moi j'ai vu les premières fois où
carcross venez avec son rétro projecteur
max je les connais ils faisaient même
pas des sketches qui fait là il faisait
des sketches max où il parlait de des
tchèques métro il s'était vraiment
dessus des sujets de balle il parlait
pas du tout qu un petit hors cote voix
next 9 d'hypothèses je passe beaucoup de
temps libre sur des sites de fringues et
décide de découvertes mathématiques
c'est vrai c'est complètement vrai et ça
tue l'oeil dans mes coups qui m'ont
historique du cours
j'achète battus voire garde nouvelles
fringues j'achète pas beaucoup de
fringues parce que je suis très très
difficile mais du coup je ne fais que
regarder
imaginez etc et le site de découvertes
mathématiques ou je lis peu près tout ce
qui se publie sur le sujet c'est un peu
compliqué à suivre mais passionne
vraiment que ça eh ben la résolution de
une des résolutions potentiel de
l'hypothèse de l'air que jamais été
vérifiées et celle ci n est pas encore
démontré
mais elle est hyper intéressant
prochaine hypothèse dernière hypothèse
le réseau social que j'utilise le plus
et facebook
c'est vrai comme toutes les autres
d'ailleurs c'est des pauvres hères
évidemment sur facebook et bien
bizarrement je reposte pas forcément mes
trucs de youtube mais je poste tout et
blake viennent les découvertes que
j'aime bien les trucs comme ça je mets
aussi un peu plus de personnel moi je ne
partage pas beaucoup de choses
personnelles sauf sur facebook tu vois
sur ce que je fais ce que je pense des
avis des opinions tu vois j'aime bien
mettre mon opinion là bas parce que je
trouve que c'est bien reçus on peut
vraiment discuté dans les com et/ou et
c'est le premier réseau social sur
lequel j'étais donc espèce de truc de
fidélité grave tu vois par exemple
instagram j'y vais une fois par jour si
j'ai des story à faire et c'est tout
quoi tu vois ça m'intéresse pas vraiment
même si je suis plus souvent suivi en ce
moment sur un stade sur facebook voilà
alors peut-être que maintenant vous
pouvez mettre en commentaire votre
pronostic avec dvv pour vrai donc qu'edf
pour faut donc là on le camp je vous
conseille de m'élever vvd et pvv ce que
tu t'es vrai évidemment
et ensuite quand je vais vous dire si
c'est vrai ou faux vous pourrez mettre
votre score juste en dessous on saura
exactement où vous en étiez et
maintenant les l'hypothèse numéro une
c'était que en 24 heures j'ai fait du
mentalisme en polynésie en turquie alors
c'est vrai ou faux ça le hic
exact c'est complètement vrai j'ai
vraiment fait le festival du rire la
première et la deuxième année là bas à
tahiti
sauf que je suis reparti un peu plus tôt
que les autres parce que j'avais un
contrat en turquie donc je me suis fait
en tout et pour tout 24 heures de
déplacement jaillir de vol mais non
parce que en fait il ya un arrêt à los
angeles xterra se prend du temps et je
me suis retrouvé du jour au lendemain
avec 13 heures de décalage horaire plus
les 24 heures de transport et je
travaillais vraiment le soir même
j'étais en spectacle à istanbul
donc c'était parfait pour être
complètement déconnecté dire n'importe
quoi sur scène mais c'était assez
marrant
la deuxième hypothèse c'est que j'aurais
donné des cours de cartomagie à nicolas
sarkozy est donc là c'est non c'est faux
c'est faux c'est que c'est complètement
faux mais c'est malin d'avoir mis ça
parce que pour la petite histoire c'est
vrai que j'ai fait
deux des tours et des numéros pour la
soirée de rachida dati dormi de la
légion d'honneur que nicolas sarkozy
était là que je la rencontrais là bas et
qui la vie j'adorerais faire ça pendant
que je vous appelle un jour pour prendre
des cours mais j'ai la même tare prix
monument au téléphone tu vois si ce
genre de phrase jetée comme ça en l'air
mais donc c'est vrai que je les
rencontrais et c'est complètement faux
que j'ai des données décors de carte
magique côté c'est comme ça je pouvais
pas j'étais président l'hypothèse 3
c'est que je serai hypermnésique et
heureusement je personne ne souhaite
être hyper mesic ces maladies en phase
insécurité une pathologie c'est
l'incapacité d'oublier donc imaginer qu
est-ce que c'est comme charge mentale tu
ne peux pas ne pas de souvenirs mais y
compris de tous les films que tu as vu
des livre que tu as lu des conversations
que tu as eue avec des gens si tu as une
embrouille à quelqu'un on a tous eu des
embrouilles avec des potes sa famille eh
bien tu te souviendras toujours
mot-à-mot de ce qui t'a dit de ce qui
t'a envoyé
bref c'est quelque chose de très lourd à
vivre que je ne souhaite à personne
évidemment
par contre j'ai une mémoire eidétique et
ça c'est rien c'est de la gnognotte tu
vois c'est juste que j'ai une mémoire
visuelle un peu plus développé et si je
veux retenir quelque chose ça va m'aider
mais je vais l'oublier si je réalise pas
ou si j'ai pas de moyens comme tout prix
hypothèse 4 j'aurais co écrit par jeff
pana cloques et le ventriloque et oui
c'est complètement vrai ouais on a on a
commencé ensemble dans les cabarets à
paris et effectivement donner des
conseils et où et quand ça a commencé à
bouger pour lui avec patrick sébastien
en fait de jeu qu écrivait ce qu
écrivait les vannes qu'il allait
balancer aux invités s'ils avaient
besoin de moi sur le numéro je coécris
des numéros on sait stimuler
mutuellement et donc dans le temps le
premier spectacle et des petits bouts de
trucs que j'ai écrit pour la télé qui
sont dedans par exemple la websérie tout
ça c'est vrai je vous mettrais un lien
dans la description qu'il ya de la
websérie donc c'est vrai il peut être
cinq j'aurais aussi le premier prix aux
cadors de la magie à cannes alors ça
c'est vrai ou c'est faux this is la
vérité exactement c'est un grand prix de
magic avait lieu à cannes
à l'époque j'avais vraiment un super
truc est un super concept et le prix
close up
c'était les vraies conditions du close
up on allait vraiment dans des bars en
était suivi par le jury et dans les bars
on allait aborder réellement des
personnes qui n'étaient pas au courant
pour leur faire des tours de magie c'est
des vrais gens et donc il y avait la
notation du jury et aussi les gens de
neil
avis après quand l'organisation aller
les voir c'était hyper intéressant parce
qu'on était jugée vraiment sur le
terrain tu vois ce que je veux dire et
donc je me suis moi c'est mort mais qui
des tueurs comme j'adore excusé tout
donc je dois refaire la route de nuit
pour rentrer à la rochelle ça m'évite de
payer une chambre d'hôtel du régime
croit tellement pas que je suis au fond
de la salle près à partir le plus tôt
possible après la remise des prix avec
mon manteau mon sac et ses prêts à
partir à la porte et je veux entendre
juste qu'ils sont les trois premiers sur
le podium donc j'entends le troisième
dans le deuxième et le premier c'est mon
nom je m'y attendais pas donc j'ai
arrivée sur scène avec eux la valise le
gros morceau le machin c'était n'importe
quoi et du coup c'est un souvenir d'un
toit hypothèse 6 je parle cinq langues
loïc c'est vrai ou c'est faux ça alors
cette histoire est complètement faux je
parle pas cinq langues
en vrai réellement une manière de l'img
je parle que le français
après me débrouille en anglais en
espagnol moi ça va je me débrouille
correctement on va dire en polonais
thaïlandais et plein d'autres langues
j'ai plein de mots de base jeu peut-être
trente ou cinquante mots ou phrases mais
c'est rien tu vois ce que je veux dire
je peux te dire yes we go ce qui est ou
ljs pivot voix est ce qui reste de la
bière voilà en gros si quelqu'un ne
parle pas la langue
je peux lui faire croire que je sais
parler tu vois pas ce que j'ai assez de
volume pour faire semblant
mais en vrai nom j'ai une quiche il
potasse est ma soeur est également
mentalist alors est elle vraiment
mentalist non sauf si c'est oui mais que
t'as rien trouvé sur ce propos là quand
tu as fait tes recherches
oui c'est complètement faux pas du tout
mentalist voilà il ya rien à dire de
plus comme et ça que c'était très
marrant de faire ça hypothèse 8 je
connaîtrai pierre crossmax barberino
depuis huit ans avant bien avant qu'il
fasse des vidéos tous et tesla vérité
bien sûr ben voilà tout ce que j'ai dit
était vrai en fait ans et il ya des
plateau d'humoristes comme ça dans paris
on allait jouer tous les soirs soit pour
tester de nouvelles choses soit pour
prendre des skill là dedans soit aussi
pour faire la promo de ce spectacle
comme ça après les gens ils viennent
voir en spectacle dans l'ue 15 minutes
par soir par exemple et donc c'est
vraiment c'était la même génération et
donc entraîné depuis très longtemps très
drôle qu'on se retrouve là les mêmes
potes aujourd'hui sur sur youtube
hypothèse l'efs je passe beaucoup de
temps libre sur des sites de fringues et
décide de découvertes mathématiques loïc
c'est faux c'est complètement faux et
c'est faux pour les deux dire que c'est
faux pour les fringues vraiment c'est ne
saigne corvée pour moi si je dois
acheter une fringue ça me saoule grave
et les sites de découvertes
mathématiques non non non pas du tout
quoi tu vois je peut m'intéresser à des
résultats qui ont été publiés parce
qu'ils sont aussi quoi mais je vais
jamais r ça et j'ai pas du tout la
compétence pour tout comprendre
est ce que je t'ai dit pour croire à
l'hypothèse de l'air tout à l'heure rien
j'ai juste mis des mots qui sonnait bien
mais l'hypothèse de l'air je pense même
que ça ne veut rien dire puisque l'air
et ça fait sérieux
dernière hypothèse le réseau social que
j'utilise le plus et facebook
robin c'est bien bien faut un tu vois
c'est complètement faux donc c'est un
star tu as raison c'est instagram jeu
réseau social que je préfère après au
même niveau c'est twitter et snap et
après un dernier facebook post quand
même régulièrement sur facebook parce
que des personnes qui me suivent que
là-bas et puis c'est vraiment le premier
réseau que j'ai utilisée mais
aujourd'hui je préfère clairement
instagram et c'est là où il ya le plus
de monde d'ailleurs tout de suite du
coup pensé à me rajouter peut-être sur
facebook le lien dans la description et
aussi sur instagram jpost des fun fact
tous les jours et de jeu sur tous les
sujets vous avez également le lire dans
la description si ce concept convient de
faire vous appliquez la vidéo pour un
épisode de on peut le faire sur moi ou
sur d'autres personnes c'était assez
marrant à faire mais peut-être un autre
sujet que moi ce coup-ci donc donnez moi
vos idées sur la personne ou sur le
sujet qu'on pourrait traiter
merci à north bay end avoir sponsorisé
cette vidéo n'oublie pas c'est un très
bon bpn vous avez le lien dans la
description avec une grosse réduction de
75 % + 1 mois gratuit et ça c'est plutôt
cool n'oubliez pas de vous abonner en
cliquant ici ci s'est pas fait c'est
important de s'abonner je compte sur
vous parce que comme ça vous pourrez
compter sur moi
ici vous avez une vidéo que youtube vous
recommander si vous la recommande c'est
qu'ils ont raison parce qu'ils savent
tout de vous et oui forcément parce que
vous utilisez peut-être pas encore noire
bp n est ici c'est la dernière vidéo que
j'ai publié sur la chaîne n'hésitez pas
allez la voir elle était très cool à
très bientôt
ciao